the movie surrounds a washed-out film
director named leak he recently lost his
mother who left him with his father yat
hung the old man has dementia and needs
constant care one night leek's father
comes to him in wet pajamas having peed
himself for the fifth time in a day an
angered leak drags the poor old man into
the bathroom and locks him inside right
after he washes the regret with alcohol
and decides to commit the unthinkable
seconds before dying something strange
happens in leek's apartment the younger
version of his mother appears out of the
fridge and saves him then comes the
following morning leak suddenly
remembers about his father and rushes to
the bathroom yat-hung is slouched down
in the toilet still asleep leek tries to
pull him back but is shocked when he
realizes his father is light as a
feather it turns out that yat hung has
shed his skin overnight and the thing
leek just touched is the outer layer of
his body and his outfit gross
still in shock leak hears his father's
voice arguing with someone outside he is
downstairs talking to a bunch of
youngsters about music and sports it is
a strange sight for leak because he
hasn't seen his father have a rational
conversation in years it is almost as if
his dementia has been miraculously cured
leek assumes something is wrong with
yat-hung and is worried about his health
yat-hang on the other hand seems to
remember everything that happened before
he was diagnosed with dementia he even
thinks the shedding of his skin is
normal like the seasons and sunburn
peeling a while later he runs to the
market and talks to the sellers as he
used to in the past he remembers all of
their names and can do complex math
faster than a calculator however when he
tries to buy vegetables he is asked to
pay off his debts first soon the entire
market runs after him because he is
indebted to almost everyone after
somehow getting away from them leak
brings yat-hung to the hospital
initially yat hung argues that he is
perfectly fine and doesn't need to get
checked but after seeing how beautiful
the nurse is he is ready to give it a
try the doctor is shown the results from
a cat scan which shocks him yad hung's
dementia has been cured at an
unbelievable rate and it is as if he is
aged back 10 years the doctor thinks
leak is trying to perform an insurance
fraud and has brought a different person
instead of his father they are kicked
out of the hospital and leaks questions
about his father remain unanswered in
the following scene the father and son
are back home yat hung collects his skin
to throw it in the trash but leak stops
him he thinks it might be useful in the
future but yadhung finds it disgusting
to save his own skin as they struggle to
get a hold of the skin leek's wife sasa
barges in she is here to ask leek if he
is signed to the divorce papers but is
distracted by the skin which is now
sitting on the sofa yat hung doesn't
remember sasa and leek having marital
problems and asks her to stay in the
house however sasa is tired of her
husband's bad decisions moreover he
cheated on her with his high school
sweetheart she no longer wants to be
with him and orders him to sign the
papers in a week then leak and yat hung
have a long chat about how leak's life
turned out to be this way the main
reason for his failure is his high
school girlfriend chimi on the night
when leek's first film flopped chimi
came to meet him with a cigarette in her
hand he needed reassurance which he
found in her love however the affair
broke his marriage and the cigarette
burned down the studio he put all of his
money on it was the beginning of his
downfall soon after he received divorce
papers from his wife then he was beaten
up by loan sharks who made him sign a
paper that gives them the right to his
organs if he doesn't pay them back in
the next three months they will sell his
organs to make money yat hung feels bad
for leak but knows that everything that
happened was his fault and no one else's
yat hung even blames leak for pushing
his mother to an early death with all of
his bad decisions leak can do nothing
but listen because he knows it is true
the following morning leek wakes up to
another piece of skin lying in his house
yat hung has yet again transformed
turning into his younger 40 year old
self leak goes outside and finds him
arguing with two policemen about smoking
rules leek helps him get rid of the
police and brings him to the stadium
where they used to go when he was in
high school they reenact the old days
when leak had no problems in his life
for the first time in years the father
and son feel like they still love each
other later on they're at home when
someone knocks on the door it is none
other than leek's high school girlfriend
chimi she just got divorced and is
desperate to get back together with leek
she tries her best to seduce him while
leek tries his best to send her away
when nothing works he holds a kitchen
knife at her and threatens her to leave
but before that sassa arrives and finds
her husband with the girl he cheated
with both women refused to back down or
go away chi mi tries to make sasa
jealous by telling her how leak used to
treat her while sasa calls her the other
woman they are interrupted by another
knock on the door this time a handsome
young guy walks in who leak mistakes for
jackie chan from snake in the eagle's
shadow self plug we recapped that too
but the man turns out to be yat hung who
has changed his skin for the third time
on being asked where the skin is he says
that he left it in the streets because
it was trash leek immediately runs
outside to get the skin back to him it
is not just a layer the skin was the
best his father has ever been weird
after reminiscing about his childhood
yesterday leek has finally realized how
important his father has been in his
life he looks for the skin in every part
of the neighborhood ignoring the heavy
rainfall then he finally finds it hung
on a pole in an alleyway leek hugs the
skin as his own father and brings him
back home by now yat-hang is cooking in
the kitchen delighted that he is getting
his youth back this version of him is
not what leek knew his father to be when
yat hung makes fun of the collection of
skin they get into an argument this
reminds leak of the bad times he had
with his father like when he cheated on
his mother and neglected the family the
argument turns into a fist fight when
yat hung openly admits to cheating leak
holds him on the ground and is about to
hurt him but he sees his mother's
picture in the background and stops
yat-hung makes fun of him for being weak
and asks him to get out of the house
because it is still under his name some
seconds later he feels bad seeing leek
cry and shows him a bobby pin that his
wife left in the house earlier yat-hang
wants leek to pursue sassa and bring her
back into his life if he is unable to do
even that yat-hung promises to disown
him instead of going to sasa leak ends
up in the hands of the lone sharks they
chain him up and are about to take his
organs out all of a sudden yat hung
makes a jackie chan style entry on a
scooter initially he threatens the thugs
but as they hold their weapons to his
neck he does a 180 and pretends to be a
passerby the gangster asks yat-hung to
apologize if he wants to be let free
however yat-hung is a strict follower of
the saying that sorry should only be
said if one feels that way he tries to
get off the hook by puzzling the
gangsters but it doesn't work they
proceed to beat him up while leak yells
in the background suddenly yat-hung goes
through another transformation his skin
tears revealing the flesh underneath and
making the gangsters run away in fear
following that he climbs up the bar and
comes out of his older skin leek is
shocked to have witnessed a
transformation in real time his father
stands naked covered in a slimy
substance in an animal-like form leek
manages to unlock the chains using the
bobby pin but by the time he is free yat
hung has already disappeared later at
night leak returns home to see that it
has completely changed into yat hung's
home from when he was in his 20s he was
working for the chinese air base in the
war and was recently married to leak's
mother yat hung says that he has to go
to hong kong to get his wife back leak
realizes he doesn't remember her death
and tells him the truth yat hung's heart
breaks for the hundredth time as he
crouches down in a corner after that he
takes his son to the final flight that
he piloted the father and son enjoy
flying for a while before they crash
this crash actually happened in the past
and caused yat-hung to lose 50 percent
of the vision in his eyes which is why
he had to retire they returned to the
apartment where yat hang continues
telling the stories of the past all of a
sudden 20 year old leak's mother barges
into the room alongside the house yat
hung's imagination has manifested his
wife as well she begins cooking noodles
for them and the smell of it makes all
the skin come back to life leek also
turns into his younger self and invites
all versions of his father to eat as
this movie descends into the deepest
pits of hell they sit around the table
like a family and enjoy the meal
together all yat-hungs blame each other
for how their life turned out and come
to the conclusion that the
thirty-year-old
who cheated on his wife was the worst
version of them all in the end they all
have to go to the toilet at once leak
turns back into his older version and
thanks his mother for everything she has
done he wishes her goodbye with tears in
his eyes knowing that she has come to
him to show him the right path in life
suddenly an earthquake hits and their
house flies into the sky leak looks
outside and sees his father enjoying a
plane ride he finally feels like the
person that he was before his life took
a turn for the worst in the following
scene leak sits by his father he was on
his deathbed everything that happened in
the past week feels like a realistic
dream to him but in his heart he knows
that it was reality it was his parents
reminding him he still has reasons to
stay alive eventually yat-hung passes
away and leak remembers him as the man
who shaped him as a person not an old
man who wet his pants all the time after
that leak signs the divorce papers and
apologizes to sasa for making her life
so difficult she was always a good wife
to him and he is the one who failed to
understand that he also reveals that he
is going to start directing again as his
friend has gotten him a job at an
entertainment company the loan shark has
agreed to receive money in interest
which might be because he was scared of
yat-hang when they last met overall
leak's life is back on track and he
could not be happier this ambitious
version of leak is what sassa fell in
love with years ago she makes an
airplane out of the divorce papers and
accepts him as who he is a few weeks
later leak is on the set of his next big
project he handles several employees
under him and is passionate about work
the movie he is working on is called
shedskin papa and is based on what
happened to him a few weeks ago in the
last scene he looks at the set in
admiration and initiates the first take
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching